in Game of Thrones Sansa Stark has a
pretty rough relationship history she's
betrothed to Prince Joffrey and he turns
out to be a psycho then briefly there's
a plan to marry her to a Tyrell Loras in
the show and Willis in the books but the
Lannisters find out the plan and quickly
marry Sansa to Tyrion who is then
sentenced to death and flees the country
in the show Sansa then goes north and
marries Ramsay the worst psycho of all
though in the books she instead goes to
the Vale and has promised to a guy
called Harry Harding Harry's kind of a
douche but he is the heir to the Vale
marrying him could make sense are very
powerful so will Sansa settle down with
this guy maybe not there's some really
interesting evidence in the books that
Sansa may have one more suitor Game of
Thrones author George Martin has written
some prequel stories set a hundred years
before the main series about The
Adventures of the characters dunk and
egg in the first of these stories Duncan
egg go to a tournament at Ashford in the
tournament combatants fight to be named
one of five champions of the young lady
Ashford the final five champions in
order a lyonel Baratheon
tibalt Lannister Leo Tyrell Humphrey
Harding and valor Targaryen which just
happens to almost perfectly line up with
the men Sansa's married or been promised
to a Baratheon a Tyrell a Lannister and
a Harding there are complications the
Ashford Tyrell and Lannister aren't
quite in the right order
Lionel might actually be second and
Joffrey isn't a true Baratheon he's a
Lannister who people think is a
Baratheon but still the pattern lines up
too well to be a coincidence especially
given the inclusion of house Harding
which is a pretty obscure house so the
point is that the Ashford champions seem
to predict Sansa suitors and since the
fifth champion is valor Targaryen
it seems that Sansa will marry or be
promised to a Targaryen so who could
this be
after Robert's rebellion and the deaths
of the Mad King and Prince Rhaegar and
later Viserys Daenerys seems to be the
last of the Targaryen and unless
Westeros introduces gay marriage Sansa
sadly probably won't hook up with her
but there actually are other living
Targaryen at the end of season six we
learned that Jon Snow is the son of Ned
Stark's sister Lyanna and Danny's dead
brother Rhaegar meaning that John
is a Targaryen so maybe Sansa will marry
him this could make sense politically as
the son of Prince Rhaegar John could
make a claim on the Iron Throne as king
of Westeros and marriage to Sansa could
win him the support of the north in the
show John already rules the north but
he's in a weird tension with Sansa
created by Littlefinger maybe marriage
could settle that conflict so in both
books and show the politics probably
could work the tricky question is how
this would work on a personal level John
and Sansa are cousins and it's not
unusual for people in Westeros to marry
their cousins
for example Tywin Lannister married his
cousin but Jon and Sansa grew up
believing there were siblings or half
siblings because Jon was believed Ned's
bastard
they were never very close Jon and Sansa
don't have a single conversation in any
of the books but still they think of
each other as brother and sister so it
does feel pretty gross for them to get
together but would that stop George
Martin in an early outline of Game of
Thrones Martin had John and aya falling
in love so he has considered snow on
stark romance before also for what it's
worth we do know that John likes
redheads
so it could go either way maybe Sansa
will marry John but there is another
possibility because John isn't Rhaegar
Targaryen only son with his wife Elia
Rhaegar had a daughter called Rhea nice
and a son called Aegon we're told of
these kids were killed by Gregor Clegane
in Robert's rebellion but in the books
Varys claims to have saved Aegon and to
have secretly raised him to be a perfect
King and in book 5 Aegon begins an
invasion of Westeros popular theories
suggest that this Aegon is a fake no
true Targaryen at all check out the
Varys video for details but Aegon could
probably still fit this Ashford pattern
because well Joffrey isn't a true
Baratheon but he still seems to fit so
could a gonne be the Targaryen Sansa
marries again the politics could work to
take over Westeros Aegon needs allies
and Sansa's the key to the north this
could possibly also work romantically
Sansa an egg or no both young pretty and
basically decent people so it's easy
enough to imagine them falling in love
it could also fit nicely with the
prophecy of a younger and more beautiful
Queen coming to cast down Cersei
Lannister Sansa could be that Queen so
there are points on both sides
maybe Sansa
marry her cousin Jon Targaryen or maybe
she'll marry Aegon Targaryen or maybe
this pattern means nothing and she'll
marry someone else or no one at all it's
too early to know for sure but after
Sansa's history of evil exes you can
only hope she'll end up with someone she
likes thanks for watching if you want to
know more about Jon's parents or about
Varys and Aegon check out the video
links in the description also if you
haven't read Duncan egg the Game of
Thrones prequel story so you might like
to check them out
they're much shorter and lighter than
the main throne series and they're well
worth a read if you're a fan there's an
Amazon link to buy them below which
supports this channel at no extra cost
to you thanks also to the patrons
supporting this channel on patreon
including Mark Nelson Matthew lockup
Ellie Jeffrey Shore Jessica Aldridge
Reid Miguel fresh aura Cusack II
Samantha K Enrique's Allie and bill
Quinn VC Gillian rocky lot Europe and
wheat man she is
you